miss Paula went home tonight that how  does that feel  I mean it literally feels like the  family lost its mom today so I'm gonna  miss her but the thing is we just have  such positive memories of her it's I  mean she's definitely gonna live on in  my heart and definitely my stomach  absolutely I have a cookbook so yeah for  real sir you have been through a lot  lately you had the injury last week your  friend got hurt how are you feeling and  dealing with all of this that's going on  for you lately I mean I wouldn't say I  am dealing with it you just kind of put  it in its own separate area and hope it  doesn't spill over and that's kind of  all you can do  I'm trying to I mean trying to I  definitely think this dancing is really  like helping him keep his mind off of  that stuff and he has a lot of fun iving  Jeff welcome you have a lot of fun thank  you I think that definitely helped